[Music]
something's got to hold on me lately
though I don't know myself
anymore feels like the walls are all
closing in and the devil's knocking at
my door wo out of my mind how many times
did I tell you I'm no good at being
alone yeah it's taking a toll on me
trying my best to keep from tapping the
skin of my bones don't you
know I
lose when you're not next to
me I'm falling apart right in front of
you can't you see
I
lose when you're not next to me
m yeah you breaking my heart baby you
make a mess on me problem at
it problem is I want you body like a
feel like a bad
habit bad habits how to break when I'm
with you yeah I know oh I can do it on
my own but I want that real full moon
black magic and it Tes
to
pratic problem is when I'm with you I'm
ready and I need some really my skin and
your tee can't see the forest through
the trees got me down on my knees
darling please oh
[Music]
oh when you're not next to
me I'm falling aart right in front of
you can't you
see I
L when you're not next to
me yeah you breaking my heart baby you
make a mess on me
[Music]
yeah I lose
control when you're not here with
me h
I'm falling apart right in front of you
can't you
see I lose
control when you're not heing
me yeah you're breaking my heart baby
you make a mess of me
[Music]
hey friends I really hope that you
enjoyed that performance I wrote that
choreography over the summer and I've
been looking for a home for it now for
several months and as I look back on
2024 I realized that the way I really
wanted to close out this year was to
finally shoot a performance video of it
uh there's no sponsor here believe me I
tried uh but no this is just me making
art on my own dime uh and I wanted to
share it with you all because it is
something I worked really hard on and
something I'm really proud of and
something that I think is really
beautiful and I hope that you all
agree um as we close out the year here I
also have to put some thank yous out
there uh big thanks to the Friends of
the channel that is big thanks to to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys uh pyroar light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible uh if you want to learn
more about all these amazing companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself check
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video uh and special
thanks to the non- buus friend of the
channel Becca Becken thank you so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission uh and also this video and all
the videos on this channel would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd love to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now thank you
all so much you all rock and quite
frankly this video would not exist if it
were not for all of you because um I
wouldn't have had the time to
choreograph this nor to shoot it if I
didn't have your support so thank you so
much and if you out there watching uh
loved this video and you'd like to see
me make more like it uh the easiest way
to make that happen is to sign up to
support my Artistic Endeavors over on
patreon you can do that over at
patreon.com drexfactor po there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards including uh I shared several
videos of this uh choreography in
progress over the months and uh there
are many more projects to come I would
think so if that sounds appealing go
ahead and head on over there and sign up
thank you in advance um if you are
interested in checking out some of my
other performance videos I'll go ahead
and link to a playlist of those down in
the description as well as up here on
screen thank you so much for watching
thank you so much for an awesome year uh
I can't wait to see you all in 2025 and
I hope you take care peace and I'll see
you soon